are you Michael I'm being here I'm good
how about you I'm doing fine
what do you think is gonna light up a
phone line on your show today the most
Game three Giants Jets what do you got
for me over there problem probably the
Giants in Odell you know the Yankees
seem like everything's pretty copacetic
right now the Jets they tease you but
the Giants that was a pretty tough loss
okay so the Odell stuff him basically
which what do you think is the one
that's gonna enrage fans the most the
fact that he said he's not getting the
ball enough and he doesn't think that
that he's giving the opportunity to
succeed or the fact that he doesn't know
if he's happy in New York Michael that's
the one that gets me I can't speak for
everybody else but my goodness you just
signed a 95 million dollar contract you
didn't have to you could have played
until you became a free agent and went
to play for the Rams or the Dolphins if
it was warm weather that you wanted so
that that's the one that really gets me
that really comes off as selfish and do
you think that this is a lingering
problem because it sounds a diet it
sounded like you know Pat sherbert did
his best to put it in a box and I
thought he did a great job basically
saying that the locker room handled it
and Odell is a grown man you go speak to
him it's gonna be a problem
as long as they don't win and as long as
he doesn't get his touches and I said
that before the game on on my Friday
show you know you could just feel it was
gonna simmer that he was going to be an
issue if he didn't get his touchdowns
and although he got a touchdown and
threw for one they lose the game but
this came before the game so any time
the Giants are gonna struggle and yeah
he wants 20 touches a game really who
gets 20 touches a game so he's always
gonna be unhappy yeah is Eli an issue do
you think Michael well he's not a
scrambling quarterback in a league that
the quarterbacks at least have to be
mobile and elusive and as long as gonna
be there and and Odell doesn't get the
feed tosses that he wants yeah I think
it's going to be an issue and and Eli's
very soft-spoken and probably isn't
going to defend himself maybe he has to
step up and just tell Odell alright
enough but who knows what goes on I
think maybe that's the best way to
handle it well I mean Pat Shermer said
that the locker room handled
so who do you think in that locker room
was the one who handled it I don't know
I mean the coach could say that but
let's see if he says it again it's just
amazing it's done with your Cena
Anderson and he you just can't keep his
mouth shut you know the pregnant pause
about when I asked him about Eli and he
also drew Shermer under the bus you know
Shurmur is a pretty smart offensive mind
he's saying that they've been out skiing
that's it's not a good look especially
when you just signed from the guy
long-term
yeah and now here comes a short week
against the Eagles who are now lost two
in a row they need it they need it they
need it as badly as the Giants right now
Michael a lot of desperation in the NFL
that's just making it fun I know and how
about the Jets that III didn't see that
one coming
where they would date they just they
just beat up the Broncos you know it's a
short week for the Broncos coming off on
Monday Night Football but those are the
games that the Jets normally would drop
I tell you what rich the thing that
aggravates you about this team and you
saw the first game of the year against
Alliance and the Lions of proving since
then they're not a terrible team that
they have it they're they have it in
them but for some reason a team without
any pelts at all gets cocky after they
get wins and they get sloppy and they
get lazy and they don't play well so the
three losses they had in a row we're
really inexcusable they're better team
than this they're at least a 500 team
you know let's see if they can continues
now they have the Colts coming in and
this yesterday was the first game of
three home games in a row that's where
you have to do something they're good
enough that they could play well against
decent teams they just can and they
proved that yesterday Michael Kay here
on the Rich Eisen show let's talk about
the American League divisional series
game game 3 between the Yankees and the
Red Sox what do you think is a biggest
concern for either team going into
tonight's game Michael well you know the
biggest concern for me rich in terms of
the Red Sox is I just don't know how
they're gonna piece it together and
their bullpen and I mean I was wondering
who should be manager of the year but
just after watching the first two games
of the series and also the final three
games of the regular season
it's a miracle that Alex Cora led this
team to a
he wins with that bull pen now Kimball's
great but up you know before that how
are they gonna do it and the Yankees do
make pitchers throw a lot of pitches and
if they do that you're gonna get a
starting pitcher out after five innings
and if that happens you tell me what's
the safest way to get those 12 outs I
don't know if there is a safe way and
then you look at the Yankees one after
the other they call guys that they're
pretty sure going to pitch very well and
without its core it's simply holding
your breath just let became too rich
Eduardo Rodriguez he stayed in in those
situations to face right-handed batters
it's almost like Korra is hoping that
something clicks in because this
there's just no short thing out there he
seems to he managed I guess that's what
happens now everybody manages every
playoff game as if it's in a box Ron
darling even said during Game two while
Tanaka was struggling and bullpen was
was moving as Tanaka was was cruising
through the first few innings at the day
and age of pitchers being able to work
through their start in the playoffs are
over toast well well it makes sense for
team like the Yankees so rich because
why would you struggle with a starter
when the you know you know Jonathan
holders a really good pitcher then it
goes up a notch with with Chad green and
and everybody after that they've all
been closers in the big leagues so it
doesn't make sense to struggle but with
the Red Sox
you know core might have to hang with a
volley tonight more than he wants to
simply because of the fact what is there
and you can't really realistically
expect Craig Kimbrel to give you you
know seven outs even six outs I think
would be pushing it so the Red Sox
starters and that's been their formula
throughout the year let's get seven
innings out of our starter will piece
together three apps and then we'll get
it to Kimbrel but now if the starters
only going five you got to get 12 outs
out of the pen I'm not sure how you can
do it that's that's the main reason
before the see the series started I took
the Yankees in in in four games I'll see
if they could win the two games here at
the stadium because bottom line the Red
Sox are really good team but they're
both had it's questionable well I'll
tell you what Michael the Astros look
terrific and that's no surprise but this
Bregman kid who
burst on the scene in Yankee two years
ago ruining that that Derek Jeter
retirement night when they just
destroyed Tanaka and he wearing Jeter's
number just started lighting it up he's
terrific
and that makes a team even more
dangerous and better and deeper and
they've got a closer so I don't know
whoever wins this series could even beat
Houston what do you think about that
well I will tell you what I think if the
Yankees win this series they can beat
you soon and unfortunately for the
Yankees used to won three more games
because I really think home-field
advantage plays a large role as it did
last year and I think it will in this
series that the Yankees are playing
right now that's why splitting those two
games in Boston is so important because
the Yankees just don't lose at home but
they will have to find a way to figure
out how to beat the Astros if the Astros
persevere in one of those four games in
Houston but I think the winner of the
ALCS is going to win the World Series
well in terms of the Yankees Michael
you've been covering the Yankees as I
mentioned for for quite some time
probably even go back to the post and
daily news days right that's how that's
how large a year 32 years are you aware
the reason why the Yankees have won in
the playoffs isn't because of anything
that you've witnessed on the field it's
because my audio executive Mike Dell 2fo
was working in a specific booth at Fox
and that is what has been the talisman
if you will for the Yankees here you
were of that Michael has that made it to
the New York area at all well see I grew
up with Mike's brother tar and I do
believe that to be true yesterday
they're both very positive Yankee
talismans I really believe that ok
Michael there you go yeah cuz Mike's
from New Jersey and I'm with Michael for
seeing all were you raise a seat were
you were you in the booth on Friday
night oh yes I was doing I left before
the game and did not watch it I did not
watch the game Oh No see Michael can't
cuz once we're up I got it if I don't
watch it from the beginning I don't
watch it I got a sit off what do you
think of that much Mike mmm it's
dreadful is what it is it's bad effort
it's a bad effort I turned it on after
this after the home run I turned it on
it's a terrible effort it's an
absolutely terrible effort but I guess
you where you gonna be tonight
we're gonna be tonight I'm going to Fox
awesome I see Michael do you have do you
have anybody on the Michael Kay show who
works on the show who is an absolute
warm wonderful human being who also just
happens to be a complete liar all the
time do you have anybody like that on
your staff at all Wow
we've got the warm wonderful human being
but that straight outlier usually it's
one or the other but both is very
unusual it is unusual because it's false
Mike which by the way is a lie no it's
not I proved them wrong more than they
proved me unless it's the Costanza thing
that it's not a lie if you believe it we
just asked Michael about David Price
Michael is he the worst picture you've
ever seen in your whole life deine ask
this question Wow the biggest October
choke artist of all time against the
Yankees I can't figure it out I you
can't how can you be that bad against
one team and be a really top-flight
picture against everybody else it's just
amazing I don't know if they could use
him in a series again and there's talk
about you know we talked about the
bullpen earlier that they're gonna use
it out of the bullpen tonight well good
luck I mean can you imagine when he
comes in the Yankee fans and by the way
rich you haven't been here in a while
Stadium yeah this is really developed
into a top flight one of the top three
home-field advantage is in all of
baseball it's amazing because the new
stadium you know did not have that
feeling to it when did that happen last
year did that happen last year you know
what happened everybody doesn't
everybody forgets this but I forget
nothing rich nice 2015 wild-card game
against the Astros it was so loud it was
louder than it was in the 2009 World
Series but unfortunately Keuchel shut it
down this did it they couldn't get a hit
off of him and couldn't get a run but
that was a day they were loaded for bear
that's one for some reason it just
changed last year it was really
unbelievable and the game against the
A's from the very beginning and then
judge hitting the home run just you know
made it up for grabs so it's now a very
very good place for the Yankee supplies
we'll see I mean Stanton Stanton's got
like that Jesse Barfield swing right now
Michael you know what I mean like where
he he might yank one out and then the
next time he'll just take
pictures and then just go sit down it's
kind of feast or famine with him from
what it looks at Jim I mean he can
either carry a team for months and him
you know 12 15 home runs or he could
strike out an awful lot you know so
after he hit the home run in the a
series I said okay now he could take a
deep breath and it finished the last of
the last week of the season hitting well
I thought that this this would be the
start of something but then that first
game wow that was tough but that's who
he is he's gonna strike out a lot and a
lot almost well in case tonight
something unexplainable happens just
know Mike Dell two foes in the Fox booth
that's your answer okay just know that
well okay take care mark Michael enjoy
the day mark no no I said Marco that's
what I said I don't know what happened I
talked for 20 hours yesterday give me a
break I love you Michael okay P there's
Michael K so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience